hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round 7 of this
year's Super bet chess classic it is how
it is a future versus the former World
Championship Challenger at janiponishi
who already suffered two losses in this
tournament he lost the Fabian to mvl and
look alireza lost his first round game
to Wesley so but he is the first person
to uh ever defeat the the new classical
world champion in Lillian in a classical
game so yeah he definitely has that
going for him uh and it's a it's a
really wild game it's uh you know
completely out of nothing something
spectacular happens and one of the
players makes it look like uh like it's
nothing like it's a walk in the park so
you'll see very quickly what I mean by
this alireza has the white pieces and he
opens with pontoon D4 and yes we are
going to show the standings so don't
worry uh we have Knight to F6 by nepo
Knight to F3 D5 and now a Ponte E3 the
the the core system or the caller system
I don't know how it was the precise way
to pronounce it I think it's actually
the coolest system Pawn to C5 and now
Bishop to E2 this is extremely rare this
is like the sixth most popular
continuation and it's just um as alireza
said after the the game in an interview
it's uh it's a nothing move it's it's
nothing you just play it and you you
play chess you know no no hidden agenda
here Knight to C6 we have castles uh and
now just Bishop to G4 by nepo fonta H3
and the bishop to H5 we have the captors
and C5 and pawn to E6 preparing to take
back on C5 so A3 preparing B4 Bishop
captures and now Pawn to B for alirez is
one of the players that understands uh
the importance of the early B4 we have
Bishop back to D6 and now Knight B to D2
and there is a game where Ponte A5 was
played uh David Anthony played against
andreolokitin uh in uh in their 2021
game but here we have Queen to E7 by
nepo and it is now as of move tender we
have a completely new game so look at
this bishop to B2 and now Rook to d8
okay just developing pieces Pawn to C4
never plays D capitals and C for
andalireza goes Queen to A4 so okay
there's no way to actually defend the C4
Pawn so you will recapture at some point
but now nipples is all right but uh you
you will recapture it uh under under my
terms he plays Pawn to C3 uh Bishop
captures on C3 this sort of dislodges
the Bishop from B2 which is a natural
Square the division might be a bit more
vulnerable on C3 so it's a very natural
move to play castles and now Knight
doesn't uh Knight's the C4 uh just going
after the bishop on D6 with Knight the
E4 going after the dash upon C3 you can
see how nepo uses this bishop to
re-maneuver the Knight all the way to G5
we have Bishop back to B2 and now
Knights the G5 threatening to mess up
there is a spawn structure in front of
the king but that's exactly what alireza
allows Pawn to B5 attacks the Knight and
C6 sorry first Knight captures on D6 uh
uh and now Bishop captures on F3 with
Bishop captures on F3 Knight captures on
F3 G captures an F3 Queen characters on
D6 and now Rook F to D1 uh not that B5
move that I've mentioned for some reason
uh Queen to C7 and now Rook capture Sun
d8 we have Rook capture 78 and only Now
Pawn to B5 that's what I meant actually
and now look at this Knight goes to E7
and just Queen captures an A7 so all it
is allows the uh his Pawn structure in
front of the king to get all messed up
to win a Pawn on the queen side and now
if he can get those pawns up the board
he will at some point create a pass Pawn
now it's not a lot and if he can survive
the attack well the definitely nice and
it's uh it's a question okay you don't
really have time to to go for some sort
of a rook lift and for a nice attack
with the Knight and queen uh due to the
back rank issues but if you manage to
play and or okay you don't want to
overload the bishop if you manage to
create some breathing room for the king
maybe you can start an attack here so
here Knight the five by Nepal uh Rook
the C1 goes after the queen we have
Queen to D7 and now Queen to C5 defends
the pawn and also prepares to advance
the the a pawn Creator pass pawn and try
to push for a win here with H6 pineapple
and now Pawn to A4 we have rooked the A8
now the breeding room has been created
uh you can move the Rook from the back
rank uh Queen to B4 defense everything
prepares Pawn to A5 with Queen to D3 now
uh going for Queen to E2 to capture that
F3 pawn and just Pawn the A5 battle
eraser and look at this uh here
incredible as it is you have to play
Pawn to F6 but it's such an ugly move to
play and pawn to F6 pretty much always
loses you the game except when it's the
strongest move to play then you should
play it and here nepo should definitely
play it but he played Queen to E2 he
overlooked uh the dangers that um uh you
know lurk beneath the the actual surface
and here comes Ponte A6 violeteza uh
threatening to create a pass pawn and
now the problem is if you capture Pawn
captures here then look at this Pawn to
B6 and now how are you defending if Rook
to B it just B7 and Rook to C8 will end
the game that's pretty much it so that's
why after the spawn to A6 move nipple
played Queen captures on F3 and now uh
it's a little bit different so feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
only winning move for alireza while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those who were able to do it
congratulations on uh going for the for
the tallest move possible but also the
most exciting one and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen to G4 yes the winning move is to
offer a queen trade as as disgusting as
that sounds I know it's it doesn't sound
nice uh but look at this now uh there's
no move for black uh obviously you know
uh that uh yf6 were so important it cuts
of the bishop and now you are
threatening Checkmate not really you are
threatening let's say uh well if you
let's say you trade Queens which was not
played in the game what happens if you
trade Queens where does the Knight go
does the Knight have any squares let's
say you go to Knight to D6 Bishop to E5
and black resigns there's really no no
playing this once the the uh Bishop
moves you play uh captures let's say
Pawn captures here the B8 square is
defended uh you resign this so no point
in trying that uh but even even that was
probably Nepal's best uh chance of maybe
maybe still continuing the game if he
wants but he he knows this is lost so he
tries Queen to D5 this involves a peace
sacrifice but at least maybe you allow
the game to continue but now Pawn to E4
attacks the queen attacks the Knight and
uh of course the the queen has to move
Queen captures on B5 and now uh the
bishop on B2 is saying and now alireza
could defend it he could very easily uh
close the game here with Rook to C2
point is now that okay you can't move
the Knight otherwise you're getting
checkmated so you have to play some like
real captures on A6 but now he captures
an F5 and that's pretty much it uh for
example Pawn to E5 closes the diagonal
Queen to G3 you're up a bishop there's
not much to worry about here easily
winning alireza goes for a different
line he plays Bishop to A1 which is kind
of similar but it allows nipple to
prolong the game by uh quite a lot
and what I mean by this is now Queen
captures on A6 of course the Knight
cannot move he captures an F5 removing
the defender of the G7 Pawn now Queen
captures and G7 is the threat of
Checkmate uh Queen captures an A1 this
is Nepal's plan and now he will try to
go for a fortress Rook captures on A1
Rook captures anyone with check King to
G2 and now e captures an F5
uh Queen captures on F5 and now Rook the
A6 and now nepo is up two points and of
course he will try to create some sort
of a fortress but the problem is there's
no way to defend the b-pawn ndf pawn at
some point either you're gonna check the
king he's gonna have to go to H7 and
you're gonna win this Pawn or you're
gonna win this Pawn or even if you move
the pawn here then The Rook will be too
vulnerable because you will be able to
check the king from you know pretty much
the entire board so here Pawn page for
by alireza and now Pawn to G6 attacking
the White Queen uh it's pointless like I
said If you defend this Pawn then at
some point this Pawn becomes weak I can
even give you an example like Rook to B6
You're Gonna Play H5 now Rook to G6 is
no longer an option uh Rook to B2 now
we're gonna play Queen to E5 you're
gonna harass the black Crook and once
The Rook moves You're Gonna Play Queen
to E8 with check King H7 captures an F7
so you give up that phone so you have to
decide which point you want to give up
so upon the G6 was played now comes
Queen to C8 with check King to G7 and
now Pawn to H5 not rushing it with it
captures because then nipple might even
create some sort of a fortress with H5
so Pawn to G5 and now Queen to C4 again
not rushing it but simply not allowing
the pawn to move so Rook the E6 and now
Queen the C3 with check King H7 Queen to
F3 uh now attacking the pawn here but
also the F7 Pawn soaking to G8 defending
and only now Queen captures on B7 uh we
have King to G8 and now King to G3 and
now uh you will see what the problem is
look at this King the G8 we have Queen
to D5 King to G7 nepo is hoping to just
repeat the king J King to G7 But Here
Comes King to G4 we have rooked A6 and
now Queen to C4 not allowing any checks
along the fourth Rank and also just
keeping the queen centralized with Rook
to the sex now comes Queen to C5 attacks
The Rook Rook the E6 and now Queen the
D4 with check forcing the king to go to
the back rank uh yeah or if King stage
seven
and then you go King to F5 doesn't
really matter so King the G8 with King
to F5 and now you can see that the F6
square is covered by the queen and there
are no pawns you cannot keep that square
defended and the G6 square is covered by
the pawn so those are the squares that
the black Rook cannot use so you have to
move the Rook somewhere else Rook to A6
Queen to C for now again attacks The
Rook we have rooked the D6 and now Queen
to C5 and now the Rook has to abandon
the sixth rank that's the problem uh
there's no good good Square for The Rook
if you go something like Rook day six
then a queen here check picks up the
Rook so instead we have Rook the D3 now
comes King to F6 we have rooked the F3
with check King to E7 and now Rook the
F4 we have Queen to C8 with check King
to G7 and queen to f8 with check with
King to H7 and now of course the move
you are expecting uh Queen captures an
F7 with check alireza makes it look
almost too easy but uh of course on on
their level this is how how you win uh
queen versus Rook Rook captures on F7 we
have King uh uh captures on F7 and he
was in this position unmove 58 that Yani
pomnishu resigned the game and a
wonderful wonderful victory for alireza
firoza who takes down not only world
champion ding lyron but also former
world champion uh Championship
Challenger at Yani promise now here okay
the material is equal but of course
black will lose all the pawns very
quickly uh problem is if you play G4
then just King F6 and you will gobble up
the pawns now you've push them Pawn
captures if you move the king of course
you go after this Pawn then you're gonna
win this Pawn as well win both of the
pawns and then just Advance your past
pawns and if you don't do that if you
try something like King then King G6
immediately gobbles up the pawns and
it's a very easy victory
uh so uh it's a really a weird game
where uh where after this uh pontecito
remove which is basically the absolute
best move nipple played pretty much all
the best moves completely neutralized
all it is is attack even messed up his
spawn structure here in front of the
king okay for the price of one Pawn
nothing spectacular uh and then in the
end uh here after we've reached this
position he played Queen to E2 he should
have played F6 and uh you know uh
nullified this dark Square Bishop a
little bit and then the game continues
okay nothing spectacular you don't have
A6 you're not going to be creating a
pass Pawn or that quickly uh the game
will still be played of course white
will still still be pushing but you have
to play F6 here so uh perfectly played
but missing F6 is going for Queen E2
completely missing the idea and then
allowing this uh I mean uh once going to
G4 was played the game was that was over
so I mean it's moved 30 uh and another
brilliant by alireza uh so I mean I mean
it it is no wonder Magnus wanted to face
him for the title uh now you see why
even after uh being away from classical
chess for so long he just you know
destroys both Ding and nepo absolutely
amazing and here are the standings after
seven rounds of this year's Super bet
chess classic Fabi and alireza are are
sharing first place uh then we have a
three-way tie wastel song
with four points with three and a half
Maxima Sheila grav with three Yanks used
of Duda Jan and ding with two and a half
points uh sharing um uh seven uh eighth
and Ninth Place and Bogdan Daniel in
last place with two points so uh not
definitely not their event uh of course
you're wondering maybe they should have
uh you know set this one out it's too
quickly to play a game uh so so uh
tournament so quickly after the world's
championship match but as they are part
of the grand Chester they are already
enrolled the regardless of how the
world's Championship ends so of course
they will be playing and it doesn't seem
like they have all that much World
Championship preparation leftovers so
you know we'll see or maybe they're
they're just tired it's hard to say uh
but yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it absolute Master Class by
alireza uh so really hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Lord of Bones
Amazon thank you for videos Dr
Heisenberg and the ding fan for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
incredible tournament to round eight
hits tomorrow uh and you know pretty
much everything else that happens in the
Chess World I will I will try to cover
it so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day